non je crois qu'on a
on a la cote
ah
on a une interprétation simultanée très
bien cher monsieur le président chers
emmanuel je suis très heureux de voir
très heureux de te voir
ces bons
ne nous sommes pas vus depuis deux ans
donc ça fait deux ans qu'on ne s'est pas
vu et bien entendu il ya beaucoup de
questions qui se sont accumulés qu'on
peut et qu'il faut discuter
dans ce format de discussions directes
mais je pense que
en tout cas nos contacts n'ont jamais
cessé pendant ces deux années
et de plus
le volume de nos échanges malgré la
pandémie a augmenté
si au moment de la pandémie ils avaient
baissé de 15% mais pour les 11 premiers
mois de l'année dernière il a
était de 17% il a augmenté de 7% et
rattraper le niveau précédent et sur le
plan politique
nos collègues travaillent de façon
active au niveau des ministères des
affaires étrangères et il ya une une
réunion récente de plus deux ministres
de la défense ministre des affaires
étrangères et sur le plan humanitaire
nous avons des relations
soutenues des eu des rencontres en
matière de
coopération régionale régionale plus de
150 rencontres et donc c'est important
pour nos relations dans l'ensemble entre
nos deux pays ce que je tiens à
souligner bien sûr je comprends que nous
avons une préoccupation
graves en matière de sécurité en europe
actuellement et je tiens à te remercier
de ce que la france est toujours
impliqué
directement pour la prise de décisions
importantes en la matière
dès le début
et c'est symbolique que nous nous
rencontrions précisément aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya exactement 30 ans avait
été signé un document fondateur sur les
relations particulières entre la france
et la russie et je pense que toutes ces
années comme je viens de le dire la
france est toujours très impliqués dans
la prise de décisions qui sont
fondamentales pour la sécurité
européenne comme l'ont fait ses
prédécesseurs
cela concernait
par exemple la critique après
l'agression de la géorgie sur l'ossétie
du sud
c'était sur la mise en place de mesures
pour les accords de minsk pour le format
normandie
et je vois l'implication des autorités
françaises du président
pour ie les la crise qui est liée à la
légalité de sécurité en europe soit
trouvée et tout cela est lié à cette
partie de préoccupations sur la sécurité
c'est lié à la crise ukrainienne la
crise dans le sud-est du kenya au
téléphone nous avons parlé suffisamment
détail de toutes ces questions et je
sais que tu as été observations à faire
la thur et je suis très heureux que nous
ayons ainsi l'occasion d'en parler en
tête à tête bienvenue
au président merci
en effet
cette journée tombe au 30e anniversaire
de
la reprise de ses relations
diplomatiques et et je veux ici redire
combien la relation bilatérale en effet
a permis le développement de beaucoup de
sujets combien nous espérons aussi sur
les sujets culturels intellectuels
académiques et pouvoirs pour suivre
comme on l'avait lancée au dialogue de
trianon ensemble et consolider les
sujets économiques mais bien sûr cette
la situation critique de l'europe qui va
aujourd'hui nous
nous occuper l'un et l'autre et je crois
que notre continent est aujourd'hui dans
une situation tu l'a rappelé
éminemment critiques qui nous impose
d'être tous et toutes extrêmement
responsables nous avions jeté les bases
nous avons jeté les bases ensemble d'un
dialogue exigeant ouvert complet en 2019
qui a donné lieu à plusieurs échanges
saint pétersbourg à briançon et ailleurs
et qui je crois reste plus vrai que
jamais
ce dialogue est nécessaire car c'est le
seul qui permet à mes yeux de bâtir une
vraie sécurité stabilité pour le
continent européen c'est pourquoi
contexte actuel nous avons eu ces
dernières semaines plusieurs échanges
téléphoniques tu l'a rappelé et tous ces
derniers mois au demeurant malgré la
crise j'ai pu aussi échangé avec le
président aziz qui pour ce qui est de
l'ukraine mais mes coordonnées avec
de nombreux européens et alliés
qu'il s'agisse aussi des britanniques ou
des américains des canadiens et je pense
que la discussion d'aujourd'hui à mes
yeux
amorcé une
ce vers quoi nous devons aller qui est
une une désescalade dont nous
connaissons d'ailleurs les termes la
situation politico-militaire
la question ne craignait non il rappelle
l'importance et le format normandie la
situation sécuritaire en biélorussie et
dans toute la région et les grandes
questions évidemment de sécurité
collective dont nous allons parler donc
je me réjouis d'avoir l'opportunité de
pouvoir entrer en profondeur sur tous
ces sujets et commencer à bâtir une
réponse utile collectivement pour la
russie
et pour tout le reste de l'europe une
réponse utile c'est une réponse qui
permet de lévis d'amande éviter la
guerre et de construire des éléments de
confiance de stabilité de visibilité
pour tout le monde donc merci beaucoup
et longtemps et de l'accueil aujourd'hui